prix nobel de la paix et chef de guerre
deux termes à première vue antinomiques
mais associé au premier ministre
éthiopien habib ahmed
né d'un père musulman et d'une mère
chrétienne l'homme de 44 ans fait
l'essentiel de sa carrière dans l'armée
adolescent il s'engage dans la lutte
pour faire tomber l'autoritaire mengistu
hailé mariam
c'est en 2010 qu'il troque son uniforme
contre un costume de député
son ascension est rapide il est
brièvement ministre des sciences et de
la technologie en 2015 et 2016
avant d'accéder au poste de premier
ministre
deux ans plus tard dans un contexte très
tendu rapidement il initie de le profond
changement et oeuvre pour l'unité de
l'ethiopie déchiré par les violences
intercommunautaires
le peuple éthiopien ne crois pas au fait
de réduire au silence de tuer et de
revendiquer le pouvoir en versant le
sang de ses frères et soeurs il croit
que le pouvoir ne devrait être obtenue
que par des moyens démocratiques
l'unité le sacrifice ils n'acceptent pas
les régimes totalitaires
il l'a montré par le biais d'une lutte
commune un activisme illustré par la
résolution d'un conflit de 20 ans avec
le voisin érythréen concluant six mois
cet accord de paix couplé à des réformes
économiques est la libération de
plusieurs milliers de dissidents le
conduit à être distingué du prix nobel
de la paix en 2019
le comité nobel norvégien a décidé de
décerner le prix nobel de la paix 2010
9,2 et fire le premier ministre
éthiopien habib ahmed ali pour ses
efforts en faveur de la paix et de la
coopération internationale et en
particulier pour son initiative décisive
visant à résoudre le conflit frontalier
avec l'erythrée voisine en flex
problème les réformes menées
en battant par le dirigeant heurte une
partie des institutions et de la classe
politique lui créant certaines inimitiés
tenaces notamment celles du front de
libération des peuples du tigré qu'ils
contrôlaient depuis trois décennies
l'appareil politique et sécuritaire du
pays
une contestation forte se met alors en
place contre l'autorité dhabi yahmed
dans cette province du nord du pays
une situation qui a poussé le premier
ministre à réenfiler son costume de
militaires le 4 novembre
nos forces de défense nationales ont été
attaqué de dos ce soir alors qu'elle
gardait un oeil sur le côté pour
défendre la nation
les forces qui ont trahi l'ethiopie ont
attaqué les troupes des forces de
défense alors qu'elle dormait au camp et
dans la vie de mekele cet acte honteux
sera évité une fois pour toutes grâce
aux efforts conjoints du peuple
éthiopien et du ministère de la défense
non seulement ce conflit rouvre les
plaies de la guerre civile mais il fait
aussi craindre le retour des violences
interethniques des arrestations de masse
et des abus des forces de sécurité une
situation délicate pour l'ancien
chouchou de la communauté internationale
qui risquerait de voir sa réputation
ternie si le conflit venait à
s'éterniser et la liste des victimes
s'allonge et